on the hill today for the giants will be
the left-hander alex wood alex wood is
in his eighth year at the big league
level
on two pitch strike three call with a
fastball
and a liner as a right-handed hitter
brian reynolds keeps on trucking seven
game hitting streak and
five hits in ten at bats in this series
against
his former organization and now john
nagowski in the cleanup spot today
and a line drive by nakowski the big
nagowski into the corner
reynolds is going to be waved home he's
going to score without a throw
no go a double the legend lives
and it's one nothing in the first
and he got him and that'll end the
ending so a run on two hits one left
giants are coming up and j.t brubacher
is looking for his fifth win of the year
so here's wade 10th home run last night
high and deep into right center field it
is out of here into the four one five
and this game is tied he's got eleven
two and two pinch swipe three called
this time he called that inside
catch a strike
and another hit for newman
rounds it past the short stop estrada
a one out base hit the one-two pitch
swing gonna miss he struck him out
brubaker's pitch coming and a swing of
miss struck him out so instead of uh
maybe going to the
curveball a little bit more today he's
trying to go to the off-speed pitch
back-to-back strikeouts here's the pitch
strike three call that time brubacher
gets him 96 over the outer edge
jt brubaker strikes out the side
not as simple as just dealing a guy and
that's a fair ball
down the third base line keep ryan hayes
into second base
with a one out double just his second
hit of the series got him
that's one of the worst swings we've
ever seen him take
bounce to short side
retired broodmaker is able to strike out
the side and how about another
yeah let's ring him up fourth straight
strikeout for brubacher
here's lamont wade he's got the only hit
in this game for the giants my little
place and a high drive to right
it is out of here
he's done it again and the giants take
the lead
man that was loud i think he hit that
one harder
than the first one he was not impressed
by the change of speeds he was on it
giants lead on two weighed home runs
here's the pitch
strike three call fastball off the plate
away
fifth strikeout for brubaker two are
gone
two-two pitch to rough rough with a base
hit the left field
he's looking for a little elevation in
that two-strike count he gets it and
laces it into left field one two
swing and a miss he struck him out he
threw him the slider down on the way out
of the zone
brubaker with six strikeouts
frazier with a strikeout i didn't think
that was possible
for frazier to strike here it is
he struck him out swinging on a high
fastball
seven strikeouts and five innings for
wood
the walk how about that and low for
over 28 coming into the at-bat
lifted the left and a long run for evans
and he can't get it it's a fair ball
and it bounces up against that screen
and now it's in play he's in its second
and third and wade is three for three
have a day lamont wade jr
there we go that's where stallings
wanted it yeah that truly paid off for a
couple high fastballs
ryan reynolds if he has anything to do
with it a line single to center
and a nice job by steven duggar he knew
that he had to be quick to get to the
ball get
you know he's going to take a big turn
at first he's going to run hard out of
the box
well it's not going to matter he's going
to line up a second anyway there you go
another fast ball maybe from casalli
got him how about that 2-0 slider
2-0 fastball and then they go fastball
at the knees
and this becomes a big league hang with
them and alex wood gets the strikeout he
was pitching for that's number eight on
the day and that's his most impressive
one
and a yet ball to short a little bobble
looked like he was thinking about
third into the dirt and state there
the pirates have drawn 10 walks in the
series making 11
walks in the series to load them up so a
couple of
defensive miscues for the giants here
and wood is
out of the game for the bases loaded and
one out and he's got the right-hander
jackson ready in the bullpen
could be two that's one
double play is jackson
works his magic as it goes four
six three and the giants hang on it's
two to one
here comes wilmer flores who has flight
out to center and flight off to shallow
right
down the left field line hit hard and
well
and out of here wilbur flores number 12
and it's three to one i'll tell you what
he can get the barrel man
[Applause]
duggar drives one left center field
it is off the bottom of the wall and
duggar's on the move
and he's going to end up at second base
with a double
tap towards the hole and through the
hole
duggar will stop at third as the throw
goes into second
estrada has got a seneye base hit runner
goes
and the throw is gonna be in the dirt
into center field
it's gonna give the giants a run and
moving to third
is estrada it'll be a double steal
there's a jam shot base hit and coming
in to score
is estrada and kusali's got an rbi
5-1 giants as estrada gets ready to hit
get into center field
a little something behind it at the wall
reynolds he leads
and it is out of here
reynolds nearly took it away but it
kind of hits his third of the year how
about that
for that well right now it's gonna be
jake mcgee coming in for the 42nd time
trying to close this one out
and he got him can't forget about jake
mcgee's slider
hard to do when he throws fastballs over
85 percent of the time
look out off of mcgee he's going to pick
it up he throws a change up to first
and that's the ball game so now we'll
make sure mcgee's
all right and it appears that he is
as he will take congratulations all the
way around
and i guess mike if you're going to win
one game win the last one before an off
date